gorgeous view from the court the city of
Nashville this morning with the upcoming
solar eclipse will bring one minute and
55 seconds of darkness in our morning
rounds how to protect your eyes while
getting the best view millions of
Americans will look at the sky on August
21st for the first coast-to-coast total
eclipse of the Sun in 99 years but if
you want to catch a glimpse you should
take precautions to avoid damaging your
vision dr. Christopher Starr's an
ophthalmologist at Weill Cornell Medical
Center in New York good morning to you
good morning to you thanks so first of
all why is it dangerous to look at the
Sun during an eclipse well the Sun as
you know has emits very high levels of
UV and infrared radiation which can
damage eyes on any day but certainly
during the Eclipse the risk is higher
because well people are staring at the
Sun and a partial eclipse can actually
fool you into thinking maybe there's
less radiation there is it you can
damage your eyes even with a
significantly eclipsed Sun because most
people there's a line that cuts through
the country where you're gonna see the
total eclipse yeah everyone else is
gonna get some exertion of darkness
exactly there's the line of totality
which stretches from Oregon to South
Carolina and anybody within that 70 mile
wide band will get at least that minute
to two minutes of what we call totality
that's the only time in the day that you
can take off glasses and actually look
at the Sun with the naked eye that's the
only time every other time and if you're
in one of those locations like New York
for instance where you don't get a toe
tap total eclipse you have to keep
protective glasses on the entire time
and we've actually have some here in
this video yeah protective glasses
because a CBS News poll says 32 percent
of Americans plan to see the Eclipse so
wearing stuff like this this is this is
incredibly doesn't that incredible it so
it's like whole of darkness when you put
these on these are ISO designers one two
- two basic totally opaque one serve
thousands of times stronger than your
average sunglass yes if you put these on
right now I don't see and that's a good
way to test it that's a good way to test
because actually there are fraudulent
ones out there right and there's a
little label one on these that do iso
certification that's how you know that
they're quality and well that's one way
of knowing but again some of these
fraudulent companies are putting that on
even though they don't meet the spec so
one way to test it which we can do in
here is you look at a bright
and you shouldn't be able to see normal
lights with these glasses on you can
really only see the Sun or something
angry
yeah those are probably super bright
yeah like I just said hologram well good
Margaret's taking the smart approach by
keeping them off won't be able to read
that teleprompter for look like 3d movie
glass yes they are absolutely not that
how do you know you're getting a
legitimate version yes so you have to
have that ISO certification nASA has
recommended on their websites some
vendors that are reputable if they're
older than three years if they're
wrinkled or scratched definitely don't
use them and then you can test them if
you're not sure if they're legit you can
test them like we just did with the
normal lights in there legit it should
be total darkness and it's actually
really important to note that a lot of
kids are gonna be watching this too it's
an education with that yeah yeah their
eyes are exact we're little kids little
kids are looking up in the sky they
won't know yes kids totally fascinated
by this fascinated and they might just
not knowingly take off the glasses so
you have to supervise them very closely
Chris dark thank you very much graduates
you can find a link on our website to a
list of approved glasses for the solar
eclipse just visit cBS This Morning Calm